or like if I was Asian I picked you know
brother fishing Bobby will just eat that
right now raw
speaking of conch can I tell you guys a
story okay go ahead I'm gonna send you a
video right now I showed Bobby this
really moving short film that this woman
Kimi Werner made where she travels she's
six months pregnant and she travels to
Jeju Island
is so funny that you say this because I
never knew what a conch was until I saw
this and this is where I got the word oh
really
yeah so that's interesting okay so I
showed him this video because of the
Haniel women the Haniel women are
Korea's first working moms from when
they're teenagers all the way up to when
their 80s till the day they die they go
out and they're sea foragers they free
dive for conch for abalone for seaweed
and they bring it back and that's their
way of living that's their sustainable
lifestyle they they feed their families
and their generations and it's it's a
whole it's it's seriously so moving that
at 80 you see these women just go out
and put strap off boom slip onto their
wetsuits in the cold rough water and
they collect their own food so I showed
Bobby this video and I thought that oh
he would be impressed because he was
like wow Korean pride I showed it to him
because he I wanted him to know that
these women in Korea exists but I got
the reaction I got from the video is
what I'm going to send you give me a
second okay well you tape me saying
something yeah can you play it killed
baby it wasn't the point of the video
[Music]
[Laughter]
I remember oh my gosh because the girl
that's in there anywhere Kimi Werner was
pregnant and then she had her baby and
then it just struck me like I want a
baby too but she also talked about why
she put up on a child what a baby for so
long is because she thought that being a
mom by being a mom she would have to
trade in her love for the ocean and her
love for you know she was basically
saying like a lot of the spearfisherman
that she goes out with you know a day
after their baby is born they're back
out in the ocean and she's like I
wouldn't be able to do that and we have
a one unhelpful advice yeah we actually
have someone waiting in the for a
welfare check in a really quick speaking
of Korean fishermen I would like you to
bring up some Jason Momoa [ __ ] real
and big finally on tiger belly